hello my name is Daniel Pham and welcome
to this week in Android development on
Monday November 25th 2013 all of our
Raiders seem to be missing so I'm back
again this week to share what's been
going on around here last week game on
return from hiatus to celebrate the half
birthday of play games in app update
news HBO Go has been updated to include
both support for the latest way furry
chocolaty version of Android as well as
a chromecast integration while ESPN
Sports Center has been revamped with a
fresh new look the app looks great but
upon closer inspection it looks like
they're showing the wrong score from
last season's Super Bowl we all know the
Ravens were shut out and the Niners put
up a thousand unanswered points just
like they're going to do today to the
redskins this week be sure to check out
another episode of Android design in
action the gang will be sharing their
favorite design details in an exciting
new format for those of you in the u.s.
hope you're ready to eat way too much
this thursday so happy thanksgiving and
safe travels that's all for this week in
Android development be sure to check out
this week's shows I'm Daniel Pham and
remember it means no worries for the
rest of your days it's our problem-free
philosophy Hakuna Matata